let's get some insight on what's been
yet another tumultuous week in
Washington for that we turn to Leslie
Sanchez a CBS News political contributor
and Republican strategist Leslie good
morning good morning let's let's go back
first to the whole issue of revoking the
security clearance for ex-cia chief john
brennan and the backlash that's come
from from the intelligence community
what is this what does this do to a
relationship that the White House has
had with the intelligence community that
was already you know very frayed it was
very fractured definitely and there was
such a quick response I think what's
different about this conversation is the
fact now you're seeing this collective
response together with with particular
actors such as Robert Gates General
Petraeus people who did not particularly
been in the political fray who remain
really quiet some people thought because
they were looking for new positions in
the administration as things shifted but
you can see this is definitely a line
that was crossed and the question is
what does the security clearance mean
anymore when you have individuals as we
had earlier in the administration
working throughout the White House
looking at sentence documents who they
themselves including the president's
family did not have clearances so
security clearance has to mean something
and they're basically standing the line
but I guess the question too though
Leslie is what kind of wait politically
does this actually have in this
particular administration because we
know in other administration's what the
answer to that question might be do we
know what the answer is in the Trump
White House for anybody else we don't
think the answer would be this is it
this is all bets are off in this case
but you raise a very important point
because the Republican Party is built on
a foundation of reverence for the
military the intelligence community and
it's really one of the legs of the old
Reagan three-legged stool when you're
talking about defense and national
security so for Republicans who have
really kind of held their nose supported
the president this is where that line is
that you're going to start to see in the
midterms where people such as we talked
about these educated suburban folks
retired military who are getting a bit
tired with the antics and they want to
see true leadership and this is going to
be one of those dividing lines Leslie we
in John Brennan's interview he really
called out Republicans on the hill
saying that they need to do something
before something gets worse with the
president before it gets really bad is
there any impact from that that we
well it's divided so a lot of people see
John Brennan is that American patriot
who is regardless of the political
consequence he's taking a stand but
you've seen Republicans basically a few
Republicans come together and stand by
him so what I've heard is you can't get
agreement on where Republicans to be
some people were frustrated that a
handful of senators said anything and
others are frustrated that they didn't
say enough so again we're very
conflicted within the Republican Party
in terms of what they see is true
leadership one thing that the Brennan
story has managed to do is to knock
Omarosa but have have the tapes that
she's released and the threat of other
tapes that is out there have they
actually done any real political damage
yeah I think people have already made up
their mind about a true showman
showmanship that is the Omarosa as she
calls herself I think we're going to
continue to see an escalation of this as
these tapes continue to involve the
Trump family and now they're high level
individuals I think that's what people
are they term is sweating bullets with
in the White House you don't really know
what is coming next that anticipation is
probably the biggest response you're
gonna get meantime you have the Paul
Manafort trial and you had President
Trump weighing in on that telling
reporters in part quote it's very sad
what they've done to Paul Manafort
politically Lesley does it make any
sense for the president to keep weighing
in and why do you think he continues to
do so well the hard part of that Elaine
is he's feeling sympathy for somebody
who basically was above 80 taxes of 50
million dollars I think if somebody
related $1,400 they would be chased by
the IRS and I don't think there'd be a
lot of sympathy for that so it's odd
that the president would still continue
to take a stand and you've seen Paul
Manafort being increasingly very quiet
so it's not a very good political move
nor it's a good legal one all right
Leslie Sanchez great to see you Leslie
thank you